do you get nervous when there's nothing
in the works or is there a sense of
freedom because of the possibilities of
what could happen yeah yeah do you also
live off that yeah if I thrive I mean I
I honestly because you know careers can
be such rollercoasters and you can go
through as a writer you can go through
many periods where you're really not
being you know really not working for
hire and you know hopefully you're
writing on your own and you're cranking
out material and you know you utilize in
the free time but because sometimes
there can be a lot of downtime it can be
nerve-wracking I I like to honestly the
ideal thing is to have enough work along
the way the way to keep do to keep you
financially solvent but have a little
bit of downtime in between to work on
your own projects like you know if they
step on what you'd like to do I mean you
know I like writing stage plays so I
like to have time here and there I I
recently I had shoulder surgery and I
was I was home it like literally mostly
didn't leave the house for six weeks and
I but and I could I can only write type
with one hand but but I was able to sort
of use my other hand and I just said you
know what I got I'm gonna finish
something at the end of the six weeks I
mean I
tough being here I'm in pain I'm gonna
write finished writing something and I
had started a new play before I hadn't
had the surgery and I just literally
just finished this new play you know at
the end of this period and it was just
so great and I'm very happy with that
particular play I'm looking forward to
continuing to work on it but I didn't
have an assignment at that time so it
did give me the freedom to write that
and during that period not feeling all
that great it was really nice not to be
had not to have somebody waiting for
something for me because I don't want to
disappoint them or something and because
of the pain and whatever so that was a
good period you know to not be you know
to be on assignment but by and large I
like I like it to be err on the side of
more some more work more paid work a
more assignment work than not it's very
it's very it's like charging your
batteries as charged you know I like
yeah I like just knowing this stuff out
there that's happening but I'm also
pretty um you know I just I'm just
always working on something and writing
something and you know we're trying to
market old scripts or work with my agent
and get new meetings and make things
happen so I really utilize the time to
do that what's nice about having a
little free time is that you can get
back to your career and your bigger
picture of your career and not you know
because when you nose the grindstone
sometimes you forget well you know but I
don't have that script I was trying to
sell or I'd still do want to get that
assignment there I want to be on that
show there or whatever you know and you
just can't do it because you're so
focused on on your work you know and the
issue at hand so yeah it's nice to have
a combination of both but you're
probably better off having that having
the work you know more work than not I
think well it goes back to what you said
about kind of like focusing too much on
the minutia so it sounds like it even
though you do like to be working and you
like to have stuff going it sounds like
yeah but that to have a little bit of a
breathing room you can kind of stand
back and see more yeah you can you can
you sometimes lose the big picture the
big picture you know when you when
you're you know when you're in the cave
and then when you get out of it then you
can look back it's okay I'm out now got
a little time where am i you know let me
let me read because you know as a writer
it's similar for directors and producers
you know you you you you have to be the
master of your own ship the you know the
mr. master of your own destiny in terms
of your career you have to you have to
keep it moving forward if you want to
keep working an agent is great but they
can just do so much you know in terms of
it's really up to us to to really stay
on top of and stay focused in terms of
what our end game is or what our goals
are or you know minded what are my goals
my goals are to you know keep writing
movies that get made and you know you
know write things that are meaningful to
me and that I hope people will enjoy and
and and all of that to you know tell my
stories and that kind of thing but you
know that doesn't just happen you know
and sometimes you have to really keep
your eye on the ball in terms of because
time goes very very fast you know and
and if it's not you it'll be somebody
else and you know we had a finite amount
of time on this planet
absolutely and going back to when you
left one career you don't have to give
to me he tells about it but were you
able to step back from a lot of minutiae
at that point because you probably had
more free time and it was really it was
a really weird time because I was so
used to getting a steady paycheck you
know and I had fortunately I had
you know especially enough money to take
to have the you know type to go through
this process and until I got work again
but that was a big thing for me to kind
of just be okay about getting sporadic
paychecks you know and not knowing when
the next paycheck was gonna be then
knowing this is just a safety net
basically and I had and and that was
that part was difficult but at that part
but when I left that job and started
becoming a screenwriter to be writer at
that point it was all it was all focus
all the time for me I mean it was just
like I just dove into the deep end and
you know and there was so much to do and
so much to write and you know you had a
like he was like starting it was
starting a whole new career there was
just a lot to learn you know and a lot
to be out there a lot and and you know
really just keep my eye on the ball so
it was an exciting time but you know
definitely challenging but but yeah it
was it was not a lot of not a lot of
downtime you know and also back then I
would feel very guilty about having
downtime I would just feel like I
shouldn't be going to the movies I
should be working on my new spec script
or something and that was hard I mean it
took a long time for me to not feel
guilty about not working but that
eventually happened when I got enough
work and like okay I don't want to be
working you know at that moment you know
so that was that was okay but you go
through phases every career has has its
phases you know and we grow as people
and you know and as we experience more
you know and as you become more
confident or more just more
self-possessed or more you know just
less beholden to the forces out there
you know well I think too it probably
did it take training for you to get out
of that nine-to-five or whatever it was
nine to seven minds well it can't you
know it kept me pretty structured you
know I mean I was so used to that that
kind of that I that kind of 9:00 to 5:00
or nine that job was like 9:00 to 9:00
but I would you know I was you know used
to getting up early used to you know
just getting my work done used to having
a goal for every day and all that so
that translated really well when I was
working on my own because otherwise it
might have been like oh my god how am I
going to organize this what am I going
to do
you know that part wasn't it wasn't an
issue it was just like will I get a job
will I be will I be successful you know
will I be able to you know really make a
go of this
you